the gyro can experience but at least we
got the first Mexican heavyweight
champion yeah that's a feel man it's so
crazy you know it just by saying I'm
gonna be I'm in the records you know um
hopefully nobody forgets my name but you
know there's always gonna be the first
meskan heavyweight champion of the world
especially for my kids you know for them
to look up and be like wow forever
yeah would be number one you're the
first ever there's no one ever can take
that from you that's it forever a
blessing my books there's what I've been
working for for so long you know my dad
pushing me embarrassing me with my
friends how do you just by kicking me
out by telling me come on we have to go
try and get the [ __ ] out of there I
don't know is this crazy man my dad's
always been there behind me so I don't
think I would have been in this position
if he wasn't in the role of all this is
your dad a boxer no but his dad used to
train fighters and Mahakali Oh a long
time ago I never got to meet him but and
he never boxed himself um no it was just
in the streets did he train no he'll
just see it was just see his his dad
trained other guys I didn't think he had
the discipline I think he owes it was
more like a hustler basically so what
was his thought when you first started
finding well he's one who put me into it
Rios yeah because I used the destroyer I
used to destroy everything all the the
toys my mom's stuff everything so I had
so much energy as a little kid he just
took me to my first thing was karate
I tried karate oh six years old didn't
like it it took too long for action or
whatnot and he put me into boxing I was
six years old and what do you know I
fell in love with the sport so what do
you mean by it took too long for action
I think we were practicing too much or
something like Tatas and shall I kick it
in the air in the first two weeks when I
went to a boxing gym they made me spar
in the kick I kicked the [ __ ] out of me
man they beat me up over seven I was no
I was six and a half your memory as I
trained a whole year and so I turned the
right
they beat me other perlmutter sparked my
first time and I was leading and I told
my dad you know what I don't want to
fight no more like so what do you mean
you just gotta keep training and you're
gonna end up beating everyone up and
what do you know a year later I end up
beating everyone up so your nickname
came from you [ __ ] things up as a kid
[ __ ] things of destroying things I
could never have a toy or or or even
like the Gameboy or anything for like
more than a week or something cuz I
would end up breaking it crazy
so did your parents give you that
nickname yeah that's hilarious
uh-huh that's what a great nickname then
because it seems like a tough guy
nickname but then when you find out it's
because you're a little kid you break
your toys that makes it even better
everything I just toys but everything
classes I don't know
it was crazy so it must be wild for your
dad to see you come up from a six year
old kid and you know because of his
pushing you and trying to keep you in
there that you eventually start
excelling and winning amateur fight
after amateur fight and then he's really
happy my eyes are they happy and like I
said he's really happy he's really
blessed he's over here and over there
just enjoying life as well
[Applause]